in LA Confidential you know you're
playing a um a big guy a physically big
cop right the largest man in the Los
Angeles Police Department that was in
the book that was in the book so I
called the director I'm going mate what
have you seen I'm not a big bloke so you
so let me get this straight you rent an
apartment yeah that is too small for you
a ridiculous ridiculous
you know you you sort of if you're
having a shower you've got one foot in
the toilet kind of vibe and that's small
and you put yourself through that why
because you want it to feel like an
oversized guy yeah it was a little
kitchen you know one chair and what
happens to you as an actor all of a
sudden you morph into somebody who's
kind of physically just uncomfortable
because he's too big for the world he
used to used to being in a room where
he's taking up a large part of it and
that got you into character just a loud
tiny little thing so it's wise to hire
Russell Crowe for any role because look
at what you're putting into the things I
mean you're moving into apartments that
are too small for you it's my job
I love my job you know but also right
for a lot for a long time how are you
dealing with
can I do this can I actually really do
it you know and it's not until I don't
know man
late in my 40s
you know where you sort of realize this
is my you can do it I can't do it
you know but that means you don't change
anything you just you know uh it but it
does mean that you know some of the
things the extremes you went to when
you're a kid you don't necessarily have
to do anymore because you know it's
available to you do you hate the first
day of shooting but when you're not sure
if you can pull up the night before you
don't it's like the first day of school
I never ever sleep enough but now I I
know enough to say to the first A.D
highly likely when you talk to me on day
one I won't have slept right so I'll be
like a little nervy and stuff like that
but don't worry about it doesn't mean
anything no matter how many times you've
done this stepped onto a movie a new
movie you still are nervous and
important to me yeah you know I have you
know it's like if I'm doing a show with
the band or if I'm doing anything I have
butterflies I have nerves I have things
that I have to control because it's
important to me are you working tend to
do my very best because not at all I
read about you when you got married you
built a chapel and you built it so that
the sun would be shining on your wife's
face when you married on her dress yes
if you're putting that level of care
care yeah I mean that's pretty
remarkable that's not trying to control
that's like standing there realizing one
day oh
you know the sun is there
at this time of the afternoon right the
window's in the wrong place
that's right so if we move it three feet
if you see it's like on a set
you know if the moment there you grab it
I call it respecting the gods of film
respecting the gods of Comedy if the
opportunity is there you must take